[MUSIC]
PUNEITH KAUL: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google AI Huddle.
Thank you so much
for being here.
And thank you to everyone
who volunteered earlier
to rearrange all the chairs.
We had a different setup,
which wouldn't have worked out.
So everyone who did that
I really appreciate that.
Thanks a lot.
How many of you are
here for the first time?
OK, roughly half of the crowd.
Basically, Google AI Huddle
is an open collaborative
and developer first AI forum.
And our goal is--
[? doing ?] by
Google AI expertise
and our goal is to have AI
conversations out in the open.
Right?
No strings attached.
You can come in, have pizza,
and have the AI conversations,
talk through your problems.
And discuss things which
you are blocked on,
how GCP can help you
with your AI workload,
and enable AI in your
business and whatnot.
Additionally, we
also have what we're
calling AI Huddle Office Hours.
And office hours are a way for--
it's still in pilot,
but it's a way for you
to literally hop on a
Hangout [? VC ?] conversation
and talk to a Googler.
So I think that's--
it's a great thing.
And again, no strings attached.
It's all is free of cost.
And our goal really is to learn
as much as we can from you--
to really understand what
your pain points are,
and how AI can enable you.
And how we can enable you.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Shantanu.
SHANTANU PAI: Hey, all.
I am Shantanu.
I lead the Cloud
AI User Research
Team and also responsible
for data analytics and IoT.
So one of the missions that we
are on in the user research--
so basically, what we
do is we bring insights
from the field back
to the product teams.
And so this channel is
a great source for us
because you guys-- you
can connect with us,
tell us about your problems.
So basically, we'll get into
details about your problems
through Office Hours
through forums like this.
And also we have
like an hour or so
before and after this session
for you to network with us.
So my goal, personally--
selfish goal
here-- is to gather all the
pain points that you have.
Hopefully, we can
turn those pain points
into product features and
eventually solve your problems.
So that's how I'm
involved in this effort.
How many of you use notebooks?
I'm curious.
OK, great.
Awesome.
Fantastic.
So Slava, who I
work closely with,
is going to be covering
notebooks today.
Specifically, with GCP in mind.
PUNEITH KAUL: Just
a quick intro.
SHANTANU PAI: Oh, OK.
You want me to do the intro?
OK.
All right.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
If you want, I can--
SHANTANU PAI: OK.
Would you rather
do this yourself?
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Oh, this is--
OK, yeah.
I can talk about this also.
SHANTANU PAI: OK, so
I'll do this quickly.
So Slava is a
Google Cloud AI Tech
Lead with seven-plus
years of experience,
working on Deep Learning
images for Google Cloud AI,
teaching JAVA courses,
blogging about Deep Learning,
and TensorFlow.
Basically, making things work.
He also has a link on
the Meetup event page.
So feel free to check out
his link and about his work.
More than anything
he's just a great guy.
We partnered with him
and folks on his team.
And we saw a lot of
interesting problems everyday.
Over to you.
VIACHESLAV
KOVALEVSKYI: Thank you.
I will probably use this one.
So hello, everyone.
Yeah, my short name is Slava.
That is my full name over there.
Yeah, and before we
begin there was already
several questions
asked, but they still
would like to ask several more
just to understand what the--
what you guys are using
on day to day basis.
So you already guys
answer about Notebook.
Now, the question-- who
is using Google Cloud?
OK, some parts of the audience.
Who have heard about our product
either Datalab or Deep Loading
VMs?
OK, one hand.
Only one hand.
OK, but someone.
[LAUGHS] OK.
Now, this talk is about--
I'm going to just discuss
with the main audience
while you guys have time to
open Twitter and just follow me
with that that particular tag.
But while you guys
are doing this,
I'm going to discuss
[INAUDIBLE] for this Talk.
So the main audience is people
who are using JupyterLab on day
to day basis with
a big in the team.
Not just by yourself as
one team member per team.
If you're using Jupyter
notebook for a small project
that you're working on
your own as a scratch book,
probably these practices are
not going to resonate with you.
But if you use it--
if you have tried
to use notebook
with your bigger team-- with
any virtual control system--
you probably know
how painful it is.
So we're going to start the
talk with Jupyter Notebook
Development Manifesto.
Manifesto is
basically a collection
of small theoretical
rules or some suggestions
that you guys can use.
But the thing is--
the key part here
that this is just a statement.
There is no easy recipe how
to convert this statement
to a nice, nice best
practice that you can apply.
In this talk, I'm going to
show some of them, some recipes
that you can come
home and actually
try to apply with your team.
But the key here that
this is more a concept,
something that you
need to try to aim.
And several ideas how you
can do some of the things
already today.
There is no silver bullet
exist right now in the market.
Different players
trying to tackle
the solution for nice
collaborative notebooks
in their ways.
And we're going to see
how Google actually
is solving this problem.
This talk effectively
featuring one article that
was published with
[? effectively ?]
this Manifesto and
GitHub repository.
GitHub repository is the source
that not only has Manifesto,
but also has some tools that
already been in developed
that can help to enforce some of
the ideas behind that manifest.
So let's first walk step by
step with each of the statement,
and then we can jump to
actual implementation.
So statement number
one, Jupyter Notebook
is effectively just a tool.
And there's any tool--
you as a software
engineer do need
to use all the best practices
that applies to software
develop [? the ?] process.
This is a simple statement,
but it's actually
been ignored in the
wild, drastically.
And we will try to
figure out why today.
Second one, Jupyter Notebook
needs a version control system
integration.
So right now, if you've tried
to put your notebook at the Git,
you know probably
how horrible this is.
How horrible to do [INAUDIBLE]
reviews for Jupyter Notebooks.
How horrible to do
large conflicts.
It just doesn't work.
The third point,
Jupyter Notebook
should be absolute self--
100% self-contained.
We will see why and
what these can give us.
There should be a way to pass
input arguments to the Jupyter
Notebooks.
And this actually
gives us a powerful way
to create things from
the item number five.
Each Jupyter Notebook should
be checked by continuous system
integration.
And the last one,
before we go in to dive.
Each notebook
effectively should be
plugged in through a
continuous development system.
And each artifact
produced by the notebook--
if it's passing
particular minimum goal
if your team or your
product should be deployed
as a production, the same as you
will do as any other software.
Now, all this effectively--
this [? one's ?] a GitHub.
You can go and check the
tools that already exist.
You can actually try to
propose some changes if you
see a [? typo ?] or
were [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, in this Talk we're going
to cover the first three
item, more or less in depth.
With some [INAUDIBLE]
we'll cover item number
four and number five.
And unfortunately,
it's completely
out of scope-- number six
as of today, conversation.
There [? is ?]
actually P zero rate.
Priority zero, that is not there
formally, but it should be.
There should be a way for--
easy way to use
Jupyter Notebook.
This is probably the first
that we're going to cover.
And then we'll jump to first--
the one, two, and three.
So if you're on the
Google Cloud I'm
going to walk you through
the solution that we have
and how we're tackling this
particular problem, how
to make use of the JupyterLab--
very simple for our customers.
How many of you guys have
heard about Google Colab?
OK, slightly more than
about Deep Learning VM.
That is not a surprising
use [? for me. ?]
But as a TL of Deep
Learning VM's, it's
not a happy news as well.
OK, so let me speak about this.
The solution and how
they are different.
We effectively
already have Colab,
which is really a simple way
to start using notebooks.
And if you haven't
seen Colab, let
me try really quick
just to open the Colab.
Oh, I don't see my others--
OK.
Never mind.
I've tried.
So let me compare
these two tools.
And if you've never
seen Colab before just--
I would encourage you to
go and try and search--
just Google Colab.
Colaboratory Google.
So what is the difference
effectively between these two
tools?
Now, let's first speak
about the Colaboratory.
The nice part about
Colab is faster start.
You effectively
getting absolutely 100%
managed environment that can
be start within a second.
You're just opening
a browser, you
could start using your notebook.
You're getting for free,
one GPU, which is nice.
You have K80.
You're getting for free 1 TPU.
Yes, it's not the latest TPU,
but still it's free [INAUDIBLE]
[? a TPU. ?]
You now have amazing
collaboration experience
where several people can
edit the same notebook,
kind of in the way how would
you envision the Google
documents [? work. ?]
Now this is a pros.
Obviously, as any product
there are some cons.
And Colabratory doesn't
give you any persistence.
So if you're working
with a notebook,
your VM is going to
be recycled each 12
hours or some amount of hours.
This effectively means that
if you install your customer
packages, is going away.
You also no table to start any
long term training because you
have VM going to be recycled.
It's not possible
these more resources.
Whatever we're giving
to you, that's it.
You cannot attach a 96 Skylake
cores or two GPUs or eight GPUs
or whatever.
There is no versioning support,
which means you cannot saying,
I need TensorFlow [? 1.10 ?]
or I don't know, PyTorch 0.4.
There is no integration with
a version control system
and no nice
integration with GCP.
And last but not the least,
right now in the production
support-- two main frameworks,
TensorFlow, or PyTorch.
And effectively, that is it.
Now, if all these cons are
acceptable for you-- let's
say you are one person
team that develops
and using notebook
as a scratch pad,
you probably do need
to stick to Colab.
I would highly
recommend that indeed,
if the Colab is a
tool that you can use,
you should be using it.
Now, the second product that we
have is effectively product--
several products
build around deep
learning VM, which
is when [INAUDIBLE]
JupyterLab on the Google Cloud.
Pros with this [INAUDIBLE],,
[? stop ?] persistency.
You're getting exactly
what you're paying for.
If you're creating a VM it will
save whatever you have there.
If you [? installing ?] packages
it's not going to be recycled.
Everything is there.
It has integration with Git.
Flexibility of the resources.
We will see how you
can easily edit it,
attach GPU, detach GPU--
do whatever you want.
Has nice GCP integration
and finally versioning.
You can specify which particular
version TensorFlow we need.
Now, the cons-- it's not free.
You have to pay.
We cannot give you eight v100
GPU for free even for a short
period of time.
Now, collaboration
feature is not supported.
That is also something that
JupyterLab as a community
is trying to solve,
but it's not there.
And finally, time to start the
slightly higher because you
actually need to stop VM.
Now, among these
products we're going
to focus on the JupyterLab,
mostly because it's way simpler
to integrate different
best practices
to this particular solution.
And before we're jumping
to different other item
from Manifesto, let me show
how quickly and simple it's
actually to create one of the
VM because all of the examples
will be on the VMs.
So this is how creation
process looks like.
Let me play a quick video.
This is effectively
Cloud Marketplace.
Let me open Cloud Marketplace--
one of our products
on the Google Cloud.
If you type there,
Deep Learning VM,
you will find these
solution on the marketplace.
And [INAUDIBLE]
the VM is simple.
You're clicking Launch,
then you effectively
specifying all the
configuration that you want.
Configuration-- the name,
just put something meaningful
for you, something that you will
know why you created this VM.
One VM is effectively--
can think about one
VM is one JupyterLab instance
that allow you to run
many, many different notebooks.
OK, this should be
PyTorch playground.
You can specify zone.
It should be obviously as
close to you as possible.
And the machine type
with the amount of CPUs.
On top of this you can specify
how many and what type of GPUs
you can use.
Let's pick P100.
And the framework.
I will pause here
just for a moment.
So these are the framework
that we're supporting.
TensorFlow, serveral edition.
TensorFlow 2.0 is just
experimental mode.
Inside we'll already prebake
several interesting deep
learning courses that been
built around TensorFlow 2.0.
Actually, I was
surprised that there
are actual deep learning courses
already around TensorFlow 2.0.
We do have PyTorch with Fast
AI, with Fast AI [INAUDIBLE]..
We're actually supporting
students of Fast AI.
We have Chainer, XGBoost,
MXNet, and four base images.
Base images is
effectively just an images
that has everything you might
need to start using GPU.
If you have OpenCV
compiled in the way
that capable [? ultilizing ?]
GPU and you want to run it
somewhere, you need the
NVIDIA driver, you need CUDA,
you need cuDNN, or maybe
cuBLAS or something else.
There is not much reason
not to use base image
if you're planning to
use GPU just because you
will have to install
everything that [INAUDIBLE]
[? yourself. ?]
OK, so let's speak something
in this particular example--
PyTorch.
Now, this is a feature that we
just have announced effectively
because of the VM.
As soon as it creates a VM, you
need to be able to access it.
To run-- to see your JupyterLab.
These better feature effectively
will give you a link.
Nice, nice link that
you can open in browser.
That link would
check your identity
whether you have access to these
particular JupyterLab or not.
And if you do it will
proxy all the traffic--
the actual VM that
you have create.
Just a nice touch
that all of you--
to access VM [INAUDIBLE]
in really easy way.
And obviously, you need
to install NVIDIA driver.
OK, so this is effectively the
more or less the creation part.
Then you need to wait.
And this is the reason why
it's video because I make it,
I think, 20x speed for this
creation because it's slower,
unfortunately.
Yes.
It would be really, really
slow to show it real time.
At the end of the
creation you will
get one particular comment--
Executing-- which
will give you a link.
As soon as you have
this link, you no longer
need to do anything.
You can just edit to
favorites or whatever.
So here is the link.
And just the showcase that
we do have running Jupyter.
I'm going to open this link.
This is your Jupyter.
So that is it.
You have fully worked Jupyter
on the Cloud with P100 GPU
under the hood.
There is some tutorials
already prebaked.
In this particular case, this is
PyTorch, so there is a fastai.
And just to make sure that
GPU is actually accessible,
NVIDIA [INAUDIBLE] to
show that we have P100.
So everything works as expected.
The [? video ?] driver is there.
OK, so this is simplicity.
This is how you actually can--
I'm going to run the whole
notebook-- how you can actually
access Jupyter
Notebook on the GCP.
So we have covered this
part-- priority zero.
Let's speak about the tooling.
The item number one will
be more conversational.
And the rest of the item
will be more practical.
So just a tool.
What does it mean?
Let's say you are speaking
with Android developer.
And you ask Android
developer who
came to you on the interview
who wants a position
[? in the ?] team.
You're asking, what are the
best software engineering
practice like CI and CD or
something [INAUDIBLE] that you
have used in your project.
And suddenly, the person tells
you, oh, no, no, no, that
is different.
We Android developers
we don't use all this.
What are you going to
tell to such person?
Probably, OK, nice answer.
We'll call you.
Bye, bye.
But suddenly, these strange
conversation somehow
makes sense for JupyterLab.
Everyone whom you are ask
about Jupyter Notebook
will tell you, no,
we're not using it.
Like, we're not using
CI, We're not using CD.
We don't have [? tasks ?]
[? around ?] with our notebook.
We don't have anything
because we are different.
In reality, this is just a tool.
There are some practices
there that specific
from Android Studio that
is for sure because it XML,
because it's UI.
But similar, there are some
best practices for JupyterLab.
That doesn't mean that if
they have custom practices,
you cannot apply generic
software developer practices.
Any Android op should
have CI/CD with stats.
Any JupyterLab that
you [INAUDIBLE]
through the source code
system should also have this.
Now, unfortunately, there
is no best practices
to link around on the market.
That is why a lot
of the people are
forced to use JupyterLab or
Jupyter Notebooks as a scratch
pad.
I have been hearing this again
and again from many developers
when they prototyping,
they're having a notebook,
they're prototyping
in the notebook.
But then because
notebook is a tool,
it's not ready for
production or use,
they're rewriting the code.
Usually, when you're speaking--
when you're diving deeper--
because you probably
will see that no one wants to
rewrite the codes from notebook
to actual Python.
because it consumes
a lot of time.
And it's actually
something that you
don't need to do-- you
have to do-- because you
don't have tooling around.
Now, there are some
cases when they
actually just using Jupyter
Notebook as a scratch pad.
That is for sure.
The same how I for instance,
have many [? pets ?] projects
from Android and a lot of
Python on my local laptop
that I not covering with CI,
not covering with tooling.
For that particular case
is, you can use CoLab.
Colab is a perfect solution
for that use cases.
If you don't need anything
except one notebook with Google
Drive for just
experimenting, probably
you also don't need too much
resources under the hood.
CoLab is ideal tool.
So this is the idea on the
higher level behind that--
behind the mentality
that this is just a tool.
Now, the second part.
Effectively, all of the part--
if you look on this-- this
is just a extension of
the item number one.
Second part is Virtual
Control system.
Usually, one was
saying nowadays,
Virtual Control system
was speaking about Git.
Not many people using Mercurial.
And I hope almost no one
using SVN nowadays, or before.
So let me show you exact problem
and what the solution might be
for these particular elements.
So let me start with a problem.
Here is a notebook.
Notebook on Deep Learning VM,
notebook inside of the Git.
I'm going to execute two cells.
Now, from my perspective, I
have not edit this notebook.
It's perfectly fine right.
I have not changed anything.
But the notebook by
itself a JSON file.
That has some [? meta ?]
[? dating ?] site.
Under the hood, a lot
of stuff have changed.
For instance, you now
have these number one.
You now have star
on the second cell.
Then you will have number
two on the second cell.
And if you actually going
to go and get clients,
we do have some Git
client integration.
You will see that this file
has been modified already.
OK.
Let's assume you're coming
back to this file after a week
after a vacation.
You see that this file
has been modified.
You want to see if
you need to check--
to comment this file.
You see that it's
somehow been modified.
And normal reaction
to go and see a diff.
Let me see a diff of what have I
done with that particular file.
Well, have I change,
do I need to commit it?
Or maybe not.
It shows that file
that it modified.
And now let's see what's
diff is showing us.
And here the diff.
From my perspective,
I actually have not
changed anything
in the notebook.
But from perspective
for the notebook is
there are a lot of
stuff that have changed.
And if you know how
internally everything works,
maybe you can guess
but maybe not.
And this is just a small change.
If I would execute
several more cells
you will have a bigger,
bigger and a more horrible
diff lying around.
OK, so how these
can be improved?
Inside of the GitHub repository
that I show in the beginning
when I mentioned that
Manifesto actually
have some of the
tools, we already
have some preset of
the tools so that
help to improve Deep
Learning VM experience.
If you're going to work
on a deep learning--
maybe someone one to
improve it and adopt
some other environments.
But as of now, it works
only out Deep Learning VMs.
So [INAUDIBLE] a small screen.
I cloned the GitHub repository
that comes with this talk.
You'll have the link
with your slides.
I'm going to run just
a small screen that
enables Git integration.
Again, it's now
has times 10x speed
because it will take time to
integrate everything in deep
learning VM that we need.
As soon as it's done, it's
going to reboot JupyterLab
This is OK.
Now, let's see
what have happened.
Now for opening
these same notebook.
And what have changed
is two small icons.
These two small
icons on top-- one
with small Git icon
and clock-like icon.
Effectively, it's
one of the plugins
that allow you to do a really
nice and amazing things.
Since all you have to do a
normal day of the notebooks.
Here is a normal diff,
which effectively
shows on the left hand
side or the same cell
that In was empty, now In is 1.
Then the second cell-- the same.
In is 2.
Nothing have changed.
It has this blue item showing
the diff of the metadata,
but that's it.
It's actually normal diff.
We do have also integration
[? of ?] [? even ?] merging
and conflict resolution for
the different notebooks.
One more example of the diff
with more complex situation
can look like this.
So this is just a
diffing of the notebook.
Again, on top of Git, the
just a normal diffing tool
execute it's on Deep Learning
VM that shows you normal,
normal diff.
OK, so this is how we can
enforce one of their item
from best practices.
This is again just
link for the GitHub
with [? Manifesto ?] tools.
Now, certain item--
Jupyter Notebooks should
be self-contained.
And first, let me show
what possible to do
if your notebooks
are self-contained.
Let's start as
usually with example.
Let's say you're
prototyping your notebook.
Suddenly, you have
decided to detach GPU
because you don't want
to pay money for GPU,
so you want to detach it.
Right now, it looks like this.
You're going to VM instances.
All your instances are there.
And there are
probably many of them.
I picked one of the chunk with
a lot, a lot of instances.
Now, in order to
find it you probably
need to go back
to your deployment
to figure out the name of your
instance PyTorch 1 playground.
Find it here.
You're already
spending some time.
Now, you can edit instance.
But in order to edit
instance, you need to stop it.
Stopping takes time.
Again, I have 10x rewind here.
After full stop, you
finally can edit it.
You can edit there.
You need to find where is GPU.
For me, it always takes time to
find where exactly in the edit
these GPU are.
Yeah, after the editing--
I will scroll this
because it's not too fun.
You can actually start that
again after the editing.
And the start process
actually takes also some time.
I have 10x here for starting
because it also takes time.
And after you restarted,
you have [INAUDIBLE]..
So this video by itself
was one and a half minutes.
In reality, I actually timed it.
And I have it next slide.
In reality, it
takes four minutes.
Approximately four minutes
to stop, edit, start.
Now, let's say you attach GPU.
You're executing your training.
Finally, you see a bug.
You see a bug, you
need to debug this bug.
While you're debugging, you
don't want to pay for your GPU.
So we need to detach.
You need to prototype.
You need to attach back
and started the training.
So effectively, one bug
requires two more edits,
which is plus eight minutes.
So you can see it's
actually a waste of time.
Especially, if you
have different box
you need to iterate.
And it is good if the company
pays for your resources.
We don't care.
You can just attach a
GPU and forget about it.
But if you're actually
paying from your pocket,
this might be a nightmare.
Now, what would be
really nice to have--
let's assume that
you're prototyping
on your Deep Learning VM
that is laptop with that user
behind this laptop.
I don't know, let's
call him, Bob.
So the Bob prototyping from
this laptop using Deep Learning
VM under the hood.
And it would be
nice when needed,
when you actually want to train,
to spin up another something--
another instance like
Deep Learning VM--
that actually has GPUs.
That small tiny icons
that looks like exactly
like a VM icon
[? because it's ?]
official icon of GPU.
Yeah, and it looks exactly the
same as icon for the VM itself.
But trust me, it's GPU.
OK, so now you want to
spin up a GPU machine,
execute the training there,
and then give it all back
and destroy that
back end machine.
That is really nice.
You're paying only for training.
But in order to do so
because that second entity--
even if it's Deep Learning VM--
it doesn't have any knowledge
about your environment.
Your environment that you
have used for prototyping
might be completely different.
You might have done
something strange there.
In order for this
schema to work you
need the notebook that
actually is self-contained.
And even better, if you have
a self-contained notebook it
might work through the control--
source repository
system like Git.
You can push it and
then Deep Learning VM
can pull it, build it, test
it, and destroy itself.
Let me actually show
how it works already.
Again, you can find the tooling
for this on the same repo.
So let's say I
have some notebook.
I'm going to actually
download notebook
with our Git integration
from just GitHub, just
a random TensorFlow notebooks.
I spent some time trying to
find here [INAUDIBLE] example.
Let me scroll this because I
wasn't sure which folder it it.
So here is a
[INAUDIBLE] notebook
that I finally have found.
And I want to take this and I
want to train this with GPU.
My local machine is CPU.
And I want to send it on
the background training
while I can continue prototype.
In order to do so, I'm going
to install the second script
from the same repository.
Again, we'll do a special magic.
Yeah, we're going to the same
repo that we showed before.
Going to clone it.
And in the clone, I'm
going to folder responsible
for self-contained notebooks.
And there is a script
enabled notebook submission.
Again, as of now it's working
only on Deep Learning VM,
not on all the
Jupyter instances.
But this is-- yeah.
This can be changed.
Now, let's go to the folder
that contains my notebook that I
actually want to execute.
I know the folder
I just copy it.
And if everything is
done right, you now
have two CLI comments that
are available to your usage.
Let me show that the comments.
Yeah, these are the two
comments-- execute notebooks
with CPU, or with GPU.
There are four input
arguments to this comment.
One, is name of your notebook.
Another one, is Google Cloud
Storage temporary bucket.
And for CPU that is it.
That is all.
That is all you need to provide.
For GPU comment, you also
need to specify type of GPU
and amount of GPU.
In my case as I said, I
want to train these notebook
in the background with GPU.
So I'm using execute
notebook with GPU.
Then as I just mentioned, I
provided name of the notebook.
Then I have some pre-populated
to the Google Cloud Storage.
You need to be sure that your
VM has access to that storage.
This storage v100 1.
So I do want to
train with 1 v100.
That is effectively-- what
is happening right now
it's uploading
everything the GCS,
starting VM, starting
the training.
This is again, fast reboot.
Each 10 seconds it shows you.
There is a small error in
there in the [INAUDIBLE] script
as of today, just checking if
these background VM actually
exists.
And the error means that
trainings have succeeded,
and the VM has self
terminated itself.
And the result being
uploaded to GCS.
As of today, result
notebook has name.
Surprise, surprise--
notebook.ipynb.
It's always notebook ipynb.
And this a notebook.
You can see on the
left panel that
is created a second
ago because it
was downloaded from
our background VM,
and it's fully populated.
So all the cells of
there is actually
kept executed everything.
And this is effective
of the recognition.
And the training actually
happened from v100
on the background.
So you're going to pay
only for time of v100
that you have to
used for training.
If something has crashed,
you will see crashed here.
You can restart
your notebook here.
With CPU you can
prototype again.
When you're ready, you
can go to your console.
You can submit your notebook
to the background train.
But as I said, it should
be self-contained.
OK, so we have
discussed these and just
to show on the diagram what
had happened we have one VM.
We effectively upload our
notebook to Cloud Storage.
We have spin up
Deep Learning VM.
Everything script
is doing for you.
That Deep Learning VM has
downloaded your script.
Then we're using technology
that has name Papermill that
was developed by Netflix.
Papermill is basically
special open source tool
that is in charge of
executing notebooks locally
without any UI
interface attached.
And as soon as these
succeeded, we've
done the hooks
through Cloud Storage
back and destroyed the
back end [INAUDIBLE]..
That is pretty simple.
And pretty simple and it work.
Now, we always were
saying that you
need self-contained notebooks.
Let's speak about what
exactly this means.
What self-contained
means-- several things.
Thing number one,
you need to have
notion about which Deep Learning
VM, like TensorFlow M20,
you have use for
creating notebook.
Our Deep Learning
VM has already tons
of different,
different packages.
Very likely, you will not
need to install anything else.
You can use [INAUDIBLE] NumPy,
[INAUDIBLE],, tons of them
already there.
But they have
different versions.
So you need to make sure that
the notebook has information
that it was created
with M19, M18.
In this way, we
can spin up exactly
that one Deep Learning VM
that has exactly the same set
of packages and the version.
This is number one.
Number two is simple.
If you do need an
dependency, please
use magical cell inside
of the notebook that's
installed there.
That's it.
I mean I don't understand
that there are some cases when
it's actually not practical.
There are tons of dependency and
magic [? cell ?] could be huge.
In this case, we do
have several other ways.
But in many cases you
will be surprised.
Deep Learning VM already
have the majority
of the things you need.
You can just install
two packages.
I don't know, maybe you
need MXNet for some reason.
You can install it already.
Just use magic
[? cell. ?] That is it.
It's actually pretty simple.
Now, limitations.
Current limitations of
this particular script.
The solution itself
can be extent.
All these limitations
can be solved,
but current limitations--
if you're coming home--
if going to actually
use this [INAUDIBLE]
with a Deep Learning VM there
are some current limitations.
And actually many of them.
Right now only works
with TensorFlow VMs.
We do have PyTorch
VMs, but these are not
going to work yet.
Only works on CLI.
I personally would be
thrilled to see a nice button.
You're pressing the button that
magically goes there, and then
magically comes back.
But for now it's only CLI.
Third one, always uses
latest TensorFlow.
Yes, I know.
I have told you
like, a moment ago
you need to know which
particular version, but for now
let's ignore it.
It always will use TensorFlow
latest even if [INAUDIBLE]
created for the latest--
for now.
It's not capable of catching
files around the notebook.
Again, it's not the problem.
You can upload your local
folder to Google Cloud Storage
and download it.
For the back end VM it's
just current implementation.
It's not capable of using files
and artifacts lying around.
Not yet possible to pass
any input arguments,
and this is actually
very important.
But here's a link to GitHub.
Please do feel
free to contribute.
Pick any of these and then
solve it if you happens--
if one of them actually creates
more pain than others for you.
Now, next two items that we're
just going to cover so-so
without diving too much--
it's input argument and
why it is important.
And this is almost,
almost last of my slides.
This is example from one
of previous notebooks.
We actually don't care
what notebooks is doing,
but it has a number of steps.
Number of steps is something
that reasonably you
want to change.
You might want to test with
a bunch of different batch
sizes, different number of
steps, different learning
rates.
It's something that you
want dynamically to adjust.
When I say that notebook should
have ability to process input,
I mean that you should
be able to override
these variables from
outside of the notebooks
without changing notebook.
This is powerful concept that
again Papermill and Netflix
has implemented already.
That's great that
they have used--
doesn't have the support.
But with these
particular ability
to override these
variables, you can actually
implement full continues
integration system.
Imagine a notebook, but when
you're sending this notebook
to the Git, continues
integration system pulls
this notebook,
overrides variables.
For example, it overwrites
name of the table,
and instead of the
production table
it's using table with
mock small amount of data,
and executing everything with
that small amount of data
just to verify that the
notebook is working-- completely
working.
And if something
is broken, it pages
whoever is on call, or whoever
is in charge of the build.
All this is possible if you
do integrate this capability
of input arguments.
So this is effectively
covers the last two.
Why it's important
to have a ability
to pass input
argument to notebooks.
And [INAUDIBLE].
Effectively, [? if you're ?]
solving number four,
number five with technicality.
This is actually all.
So this is five elements if
we're counting 0, six elements.
We have not covered
the last one.
As I said, this part
yet is out of scope.
Just t recap, just to
mentioned this is more an item
that you should aim for.
GitHub has script that
will help you already
to [INAUDIBLE] them.
But don't think
about [INAUDIBLE]
is a productional solution
that they can [INAUDIBLE] you.
There will be a lot of problem.
But it will give you some flavor
of how future of the notebooks
might look like.
And that is all.
Thank you very much, you guys.
Let's move to the question, QA
part, if there is any question.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Oh, we have a question.
Can someone help with
surpassing the mic?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It could
be a silly question,
but can you compose notebooks?
Can you include one notebook
in another and then run it?
Do you have that capability?
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI: Oh, OK.
Yeah, just want to mention--
there is no silly question.
There is only silly answers.
But yes, so question was if I
can use one notebook in another
and somehow.
Yes, you can.
I mean, you cannot
with Vanilla Notebook.
You do need to install
several plugins of Papermill
or something that allow
you this capability.
But there are several
solution on the market already
that effectively allow
you to say something,
I need variable a from
the notebook "blah",
and it will execute
notebook "blah"
until a is populated
and then will import a.
So that is already possible.
Yeah.
Even though
technically solvable,
it's open question
about best practices
whether this is
recommended way or not.
My personal take on this that if
you're using generalized logic
it's better generic logic to
be just a pure Python, if you
want, with just imports.
But technically, yes.
You still can import one
notebook from another.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Yep?
Can you please pass the mic?
Yeah, sorry.
Because with a microphone
you guys will be recorded.
- There's usually
another one there.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Oh, we do have another one.
AUDIENCE: So you are
talking [INAUDIBLE] tests.
So you were saying that if
we can input parameters then
we can just change the table
name or some part of the table
name.
And then we can read like,
more table names and--
so it's your vision
that those table--
the test tables-- will be sort
of automatically generated?
Or you are envisioning something
that you have to create a table
and then the test case is you--
the rows that you want to test
you will have to write it.
Because that's pretty painful.
And if you have two tables,
[? you ?] [? will ?] [? just ?]
create more tables but,
otherwise it will be kind
of hard to create tables
like with all the edge cases.
What's your regional testing?
Because in general
testing programs
where used to it, by testing
programs that process data--
the logic, the data logic-- we
are not used to it in the data
industry.
Right?
Kind of.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you envision that?
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Your question's
actually absolutely right.
If you're going to manually
[? mock ?] the database
it might be kind of painful.
So there are two things here.
First of all, for notebooks
usually the simplest ways--
let me first say one more thing.
So you have usually most popular
union test and function test.
Right?
For notebooks, it's harder
to do [INAUDIBLE] the test.
It's simpler to do
the function test
when they're writing
the whole notebook.
Now in this particular example,
that I showed to you just
writing input viable will force
you to create yourself manually
a table, which is horrible.
But this is just the first step.
The second step you still can
have a normal Python test that
will generate data that will
call training on that data
and will check the results.
I have not showcased here
the actual CI, but CI
that we halfway demo
actually doing like this.
So because it's not just
deploying background training.
It's first generate data,
deploys background training,
and checks that
the artifact that
notebooks submitting actually
has results from that table.
Just to make sure
that it's working.
What is we right now
definitely missing
is ability to go even deeper
and do for instance, unit tests.
Like particular
cell, that you can
[? deconstruct ?] that part.
No, they cannot.
AUDIENCE: For the unit
test, you will come to--
make you more modular or
identify [INAUDIBLE] modules
different parts of the--
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI: Correct.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then
[INAUDIBLE] testing.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
That part will be harder,
but yes it's possible.
Definitely, yes.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I think
I got my question.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So you, at the
beginning of the Talk,
you were mentioning
[? DataLab ?]
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Correct, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
mean, you didn't show it.
VIACHESLAV
KOVALEVSKYI: Oh, yeah.
I asked if someone knows
Datalab So effectively, yeah.
Indeed, I haven't shown it.
And one of the reasons
because you can see--
you can think about Deep
Learning VM solution
is Datalab v2.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So that's already
there somewhere?
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Deep Learning VMs?
AUDIENCE: No, Datalab v2.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
The solution
Deep Learning VM is by
itself a Datalab v2.
So it's reincarnation.
It's not yet as
[INAUDIBLE] the features.
That's why you wouldn't
find the statement yet.
AUDIENCE: Oh,
that's my question.
OK.
Good.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
But at some point
it will have parity of the
features plus all the features.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Anything else?
OK.
Then, thank you, guys.
Have a nice evening.
[APPLAUSE]